[Applause]
in death as in life Paul O'Grady still
draws a crowd hundreds lining the root
of his funeral Cortez through this quiet
corner of Kent to say goodbye to not
just a neighbor but a National Treasure
it's important to be here today because
he's just amazed
and as a family we all love and adore
him um it's so special
O'Grady's husband accompanied The
Carriage with one of the couple's dogs
as they laid to rest not just the
Entertainer but his drag queen alter ego
too Lily Savage's distinctive hairpiece
a typically witty centerpiece and what
else but lilies to top the coffin I
really miss him because he was a great
great talent he knew when to hang up the
dress he knew exactly what he was doing
and his love for Animals I mean I
remember lots of times talking to me and
saying I prefer animals to human beings
among the mourners Rolling Stones
guitarist Ronnie Wood and the comedians
Joe brand and Julian Clary
but amidst the cast of comics it was the
guard of Honor outside the church that
put a smile on people's faces dogs from
Battersea dogs and cats home in
recognition of the worker Grady did to
help it since his death a tribute fund
set up by the charity has raised nearly
three hundred thousand pounds he was a
big big part of Battersea and it feels
like a little bit of battersea's Hearts
has slowed down today as well because of
Paul
he was a Saturday night TV staple but
his Fame didn't Define him remembered
here as a man of the people and their
pets either Bennett Sky News